Today, we're turning tiny tips into big wins.
Quinn Tran, creator of CodeCut.ai, has shipped hundreds of bite-sized Python and data science snippets across four years.
We dig into open source tools you can use right now, cleaner workflows, and why notebooks and scripts don't have to be enemies.
If you want faster insights with fewer yak shaves, this one's packed with takeaways you can apply before lunch.
Let's get into it.
This is Talk Python To Me, Episode 522, recorded September 4th, 2025.
Welcome to Talk Python To Me, a weekly podcast on Python.
This is your host, Michael Kennedy.
Follow me on Mastodon where I'm @mkennedy and follow the podcast using @talkpython, both accounts over at fosstodon.org and keep up with the show and listen to over nine years of episodes at talkpython.fm. If you want to be part of our live episodes, you can find the live streams over on YouTube. Subscribe to our YouTube channel over at talkpython.fm/youtube and get notified about upcoming shows. This episode is brought to you by Sentry. Don't let those errors go unnoticed, use Sentry like we do here at Talk Python. Sign up at talkpython.fm/sentry. And it's brought to you by Agency. Discover agentic AI with Agency. Their layer lets agents find, connect, and work together, any stack, anywhere. Start building the internet of agents at talkpython.fm/agency, spelled A-G-N-T-C-Y. Quinn, welcome to Talk Python.
Great to have you here.
Happy to be here.
Yes, I'm happy to have you here. It's going to be a super fun data science topic. You've got a really cool project over at CodeCut.ai. And one of our listeners reached out and said, you have Quinn on because she's doing amazing stuff over at CodeCut.ai. And I'm really getting a lot of value out of it. And I'd love to hear more about this project and maybe dive into some of the topics there.
So we're going to have a really great time talking about that.
But before we get to those, really quick introduction for everyone.
Who are you?
Yeah.
Hi, everybody.
I'm Khuyen Tran.
I'm a developer advocate at Nixler.
I am also the founder of CodeCut, where I share daily tips on both LinkedIn and my news through my newsletter.
and I send out short tips which have about data science and Python in the form of code snippets that is very easy to digest in two minutes or three times a week.
Three times a week.
Yeah.
That's a lot.
Yes, it's a lot of work, but I have been doing it for four years, I think.
So I have been writing tips,
writing Python snippets for like basically every day of the week.
on the weekday for four years.
Yeah, very fun.
And you also have longer form articles there.
Yes, that is correct.
I also enjoy writing long form articles that dive deeper into open source.
So majority of the time, like 95% of the time, I write about open source, Python data science related tools.
So very specific.
And I like to really explore how, you know, what should data scientists use this tool and how they use it.
And my assumption for every article is data scientists are very busy.
And if they only have five minutes to read this article, they will be able to get some takeaway from this tool and be able to apply right away.
So you will see that as a common theme for snippets, micro snippets, as for a newsletter, like very short, very easy to digest, as well as article, even though it's long form, but also very, like if they want to, they can skim it, get something out of it.
Or if they really want to like die differ, you can sit down and like call along and most will work for getting out of it.
Yeah, I agree.
I read a bunch of your articles and I think you can certainly get it a lot even if you just have only time to skim them.
I learned a couple of extra new tools.
I think that we're going to have a lot of fun to talk about as well.
So how do people get your code snippets?
Is that through your newsletter or how you do that?
Yeah, people get my code snippets through my newsletter.
And if you go to the front page, see if you find how it looks like.
Yes, that's how it looks.
So just for the audience who's listening, so the form of my newsletter is I would.
So I would extract some specific feature out of the tool, right?
Because if one tool can have many features and you don't want to talk about all the features in one code snippet, it will be really difficult to digest.
So I pick one feature.
I compare it with something that people already know.
For example, in the screen we see we are comparing between a regular expression, X library and DFLIP and we try I want to compare something people already know, something that is less and all, to highlight okay, we see the typical problem with the tool that people already know and here's a solution and this tool offers the solution and so that's through CoSnipit.
My philosophy when it comes to teaching people is it's better to show than to So I put a lot of effort into making it very easy for people to, when they look at the code snippet, they can understand.
But of course, there's supported text.
So if you scroll down a bit more, you can see the format.
Yeah, we see the problem solution.
The problem is, I will just read it out loud here.
Red X preprocessing achieves exact matching but fails completely on typos like iPhone 14 Pro with like two double R max.
Delusion definitely provides similarity scoring that tolerates typos and character variations, enabling approximate matching where Red X fails.
And they can view the full article fail on, but it needs to be digested within the newsletter.
Yeah, I think you could probably read that and get a good bit of information out of that in like one minute.
That's really nice.
And the idea you're highlighting here is like, sure, you can search if you're doing data science, text, NLP type of stuff.
If you search with regular expressions, you might find things.
But what if the spacing is different between them or somebody puts a comma or they put iPhone 14 without a space between the 14 and the iPhone, right?
Like all those things are really tricky to catch every variation.
So there's better tools like DFLIP, which we'll probably talk about again later in an article, right?
And in the article, I highlight a lot more tools.
So it's from like REC-X to DFLIP.
And then if you want to like even better, then fuzzy matching, right?
And then if even you want semantic capture, then that's another tool.
And then, of course, you can go down all the spaCy route and into LLMs and like the whole spectrum, right?
But just knowing about this, because sometimes you don't want full machine learning.
You just want kind of like regular expressions, but not so hard.
That's correct.
Like something that gets the job done.
To me, the iNewTool is something that works right out of the box without a lot of boilerplate code and not too many dependencies.
Yeah, that's really, really important.
So let's talk about the origins of CodeCut.ai.
Why did you start it?
So I started when I was in college, so four years.
So I started to, I didn't start the website.
So I started sharing my tips first.
I started on LinkedIn, right?
So I make a commitment to myself that I'm going to, so I initially, I write a lot of articles.
I push out two to three articles on ProWords Data Science every week.
And I make the commitment.
I want to do that every week.
And then I was not very active on LinkedIn.
And then I read a book called Share Your Work.
And it said, know how messy your work is, you should just share it.
And I was very into open source tools.
And I often just sent a message to my friends and said, hey, check this out.
This is so cool.
And I was like, what if I could share it with more people?
So I started to, you know, put out some of the things that I'm excited about on LinkedIn.
And initially, I was so afraid.
People were like, what are you talking about?
You don't know what you're talking about.
Yeah.
But people are also very excited about it.
And I was like, oh, great.
I shared something I'm excited about.
And I have some other people and everybody excited about the tool.
I love that.
So I keep doing it.
Initially, I do it like every day.
So seven days per week, share every day.
Later, I was like, okay, I'll give myself the weekend off.
But I started to do, I think, over 500 tips.
And then people was like, where can I find the old one, right?
Because if you want to, let's say, if you are interested in machine learning tools or data processing tools, how do you find it on LinkedIn?
There's no way for you to categorize.
So I started to go back to most of my, it's there's so many.
So I try as many as I can, put it into a website.
So it was at the time I just find like some domain.
It's called mass data simplified.
And then I just put a bunch there and then I send out some newsletter.
So very, very not Polish at all.
And I just want to have a place to capture it.
And then later I figure out that people was, a lot of time people do have typo when they type because it's very long URL.
So I try to make it something very short and actually capture what I will do in cold cut.
So it becomes cold cut.
Yeah.
I like the aesthetic of it.
It looks nice.
It's got these soft, warm colors.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I try to keep everything kind of like a cotton candy.
So like blue and pink.
Yeah.
Cotton candy definitely comes through.
I can see that for sure.
What platform did you use to build it?
I use WordPress.
Nice.
So for articles, I'm creating a workflow where basically I write all my articles in, you know, Quarto, like DocuS.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I realized that, so I write and also I run my code in Quarto.
And then I use a WordPress API to push it to my article in blog.
So I do a lot.
It's easier than, and I don't use a WordPress editor to create the article.
I use VS Code through QMD.
But for the aesthetic, why I like progress because I can like drag and drop.
And I'm not a front-end developer,
but it works for me.
Yeah.
You know, it's interesting.
I think a lot of people who are developers get hung up feeling like they have to create their website in the same language or technology that they're an expert in.
You know, if you're a Python developer, you're like, well, how do I create a website in Python for my blog or, you know, whatever.
language, right? But I think there's a lot of value in just saying like, it's just a tool, I'm just going to pick it and it's going to be great. Like for example, I had for a long time, I had my stuff in WordPress under my own domain for my blog and other things. And I finally decided to move on to Hugo, but Hugo is also not Go. It's not Python, it's Go. And it's just build static sites. And I think it's really, you know, it's good if you know the technology, but it's It's certainly not something I think people should get overly hung up on because you lose out on good tools that way, right?
Yeah, exactly.
And I mean, you can learn, like, you can learn any language, right?
If you know one language, you can learn, you're kind of guessing another, especially now with AI.
Yeah, that's such an interesting topic.
I do think that's actually really changed a lot of things.
It's like, well, I could work with this, but I know I'll get stuck on something.
And now you can just ask an agentic AI, like, I'm stuck on this.
Okay, here you go, you know?
And even if it's not perfect, it really, really helps handle, juggle different types of technology.
Yes, exactly.
Yeah, super cool.
So tell me more about this Quarto thing.
I didn't intend to talk about this, but I find it really interesting.
Do you write in Markdown?
Do you write in HTML?
What do you write in and then publish?
Yeah, okay.
So I write in Quarto.
It's in Markdown, right?
I told somebody who doesn't know it's in Markdown, but it's basically really similar to.md.
The only difference is you can execute the code.
So my really favorite stack is in VS Code.
I have Quarto on the left side, and then I open a.qmd file.
People can just imagine it's like a.qmd file.
But you can click the button and you can execute.
so it's very similar to a notebook right but I like it I really enjoy running in markdown and it's just like a very clean right compared to a notebook it's a big QMD you think can think of like a markdown notebook just markdown and you can execute the code and this and then so after I have the image, I have the code, everything, I will, so I create some Python functions to clean it up a bit. Now, like, for example, if there's some cell that I roll, I don't want to show it on WordPress, on my website, I will say echo is false, right? It's just like a comment, Python comment on the top of the cell, as you will not show in the website, which is great. And then I can just run publish to WordPress and it's publish to WordPress. What is nice about it is let's say later some of the content is I want to change let's say in three articles I mentioned something like a link to something but now it's broken. So what I can do is I can just like you know click search by all the instances of it, update it and then I run the function sync to WordPress and then it will sync and hey, I don't need to manually go through each of it.
Yeah, that's really nice.
And it'll just fix all the articles that needed to be changed.
Yeah, okay.
This portion of Talk Python To Me is brought to you by Sentry.
Over at Talk Python, Sentry has been incredibly valuable for tracking down errors in our web apps, our mobile apps, and other code that we run.
I've told you the story how more than once I've learned that a user was encountering a bug through Sentry and then fix the bug and let them know it was fixed before they contacted me.
That's pretty incredible.
Let me walk you through the few simple steps that you need to add error monitoring and distributed tracing to your Python web app.
Let's imagine we have a Flask app with a React front end and we want to make sure there are no errors during the checkout process for some e-commerce page.
I don't know about you, but anytime money and payments are involved, I always get a little nervous writing code.
We start by simply instrumenting the checkout flow.
To do that, you enable distributed tracing and error monitoring in both your Flask backend and your React frontend.
Next, we want to make sure that you have enough context that the frontend and backend actions can be correlated into a single request.
So we enrich a Sentry span with data context.
In your React checkout.jsx, you'd wrap the submit handler in a Sentry start span call.
Then it's time to see the request live in a dashboard.
We build a real-time Sentry dashboard.
You spin up one using span metrics to track key attributes like cart size, checkout duration, and so on, giving you one pain for both performance and error data.
That's it.
When an error happens, you open the error on Sentry, and you get end-to-end request data and error tracebacks to easily spot what's going on.
If your app and customers matter to you, you definitely want to set up Sentry like we have here at Talk Python.
Visit talkpython.fm/sentry and use the code TALKPYTHON, all caps, just one word, that's talkpython.fm/century code talkpython thank you to century for supporting the show notebooks are awesome and the idea of notebooks are you know they really change the game i think a lot but you don't necessarily want to see all of that when your your goal is mostly writing right like you don't necessarily need to see all the import statements if you're only going to focus on one cell worth of code
and it's not about the import, right?
Right, especially when my goal is to make it as easy as possible for data scientists to skip.
And you know, when you skip,
it's like a block of code,
you're like, okay, I skip, I'm done.
Like, I'll read this the next time.
But my goal is always raise small code snippet and highlight the core features of the tool.
And a lot of time, like you need to hide the unnecessary code, right?
in order for that to happen.
Yeah, yeah, I totally agree.
People can get hung up on completeness and it really takes away from the essence of just like skimming it.
And also I think that this workflow, it sounds like this is one of the things that made it possible for you to do this frequently, like three, four times a week instead of getting overwhelmed, right?
Yeah, I really need to learn so many tricks in order to, I guess it's a good thing, right?
It pushed me to be more productive.
Like I learned a bunch of shortcuts because, you know, without shortcuts, I cannot get things done quickly.
So I know a lot of these code shortcuts.
And like I use a text expansion tool.
It's called Expansal.
And it's game changer.
I can like, you know, like view the code.
This article, right?
If you can just colon, doc, something, something, like two words, and then it's expand the whole text.
And then you can fill in the blank.
I need to learn multiple tricks and also just automate things is how I can get it out.
But yeah, what I still find is, so by doing that, I can actually focus on the essence of the blog, which is to make it as easy as possible to digest as well as researching, which is very important.
Yeah, absolutely.
I love your philosophy here.
I can see why the site is popular.
And the show your work, I think that's a great philosophy as well.
It's like, get it out there even if it's messy and get it out there even if it's incomplete, right?
That's the idea?
Yes, exactly.
And I really do recommend it for especially people who try to find a job, right?
At the time, I kind of like another side effect of it is you show people what you know.
because so many people, they know a lot, but they don't share, right?
And if you let employers to find you by guessing what you know or look at your resume, it's very hard because now with AI, everybody has very polished, very nice resume.
So why should they choose you over another person?
But by showing your work, by showing even the messy one, right, They will be able to see, okay, this is what they're interested in.
This is what makes them excited about.
And this is what they know.
Then they will be able to imagine how they can use you in their company.
And that's how, because of me sharing my articles as well as LinkedIn posts early on when I was in college, I was able to get multiple internships in data science.
Yeah, super neat.
And, you know, you're in developer relations and I think there's a strong communication aspect of that as well.
And this is just another example of like, yeah, you want to hire me for this thing?
I'm already doing it, right?
Like one of my first important jobs I got, I was doing a lot of speaking at user groups and meetups.
They weren't called meetups then because meetup.com didn't exist.
But, you know, they were meetups.
And I got a message from a company and they said, hey, we saw you talking to this place and that place.
And you're doing that for free.
we'd pay you to do this if you want to do this for a job.
I'm like, great.
Where do I sign up?
I didn't even have to apply.
They just reached out to me.
And the timing was perfect because I had quit my longtime job a week before.
And I'm like, okay, well, I was about to start looking for a new job.
But I guess you look for a new job after you quit your job.
That's very brave.
Were you like intended to take a break or something?
No, I was not as brave as it sounded.
I am my wife got her PhD and finished and she was getting her first professor job on the other side of the country.
And so I was like, well, I'll wait till we get there and look for a job because it was, you know, San Diego to New Jersey level of travel.
It was far. Right. So I figured I'll find something there.
I see. And then you got a new job.
Yeah. I think I'd quit my job, but I was still working for a month, you know, because I knew I was going to be moving in a while.
And so, like, okay, guys, I'm leaving in a month, six weeks or whatever.
And about that time, people reached out.
So it was a perfect, perfect deal.
I see.
But just like you said, it's because of the stuff I was doing out in public, right?
Right.
Yeah.
Okay.
So let's dive in.
Let's dive into CodeCut here.
And the idea I thought is maybe we could just go through a handful of articles.
We picked 10.
I don't know how much time we have to go through all of them.
We probably can get through all of them.
But I think this will give people an idea of what they can get from CodeCut.
But also, I just think there's a bunch of interesting data science ideas and tools.
Yeah.
Kind of like that diff lib that we talked about.
So I think it'll be a good blend of that type of stuff to talk about.
So let's start with an article called Goodbye pip and Poetry, Why uv Might Be All That You Need.
So tell us about this and then we can dive in a bit.
Yeah, so I think a lot of people have heard of uv, which is like dependency management tool.
But let me, for people who don't know about it, just kind of give some quick reason why uv is, might be something that you want to look into.
So a lot of data scientists know conda and no peep, right?
I think poultry is a little bit less common.
But for a while, poultry is like a modern tool that allows you to manage so many things, right?
Like dependency management and virtual environment.
And you can handle.
Anyway, so there's a lot of things in poultry.
But something that I didn't like about poultry is it's pretty slow for dependency management.
But when it comes to uv, it's quick, airy.
like it replaced many things.
And even if you are using pip, you don't want to learn new tool.
Basically, you can just use uv pip install, something, something, and you have a speed boost.
And yeah, so I grow an entire article about uv and I also compare it with the existing tool to give people some motivation on switching it to uv.
It's so easy to switch, so why not?
Yeah, I think I am a huge fan of uv.
I actually just interviewed Charlie Marsh for his next project, pyx.
Oh, nice.
Two days ago, yeah.
So uv is going to get even better.
I just pulled up the performance story for uv compared to poetry and Pipsync.
And yeah, it's, what is that, 20 times faster than poetry and way faster than everything else.
Insane.
Yeah, it's Rust because of the Rust.
I think Rust and then also they just rethought the caching and other, they just, it's Rust plus a bunch of new ideas that came together to make it work really, really well.
And honestly, I feel a little bit, I feel a little bit bad for the other tools.
Like I'm a big fan of pip-tools and PIPX.
Me too.
And, you know, those things are really great.
And we'll come back and talk about them a bit, I think, as well.
But I think those tools laid the foundation for what uv is doing.
And uv sort of naturally brought these together.
But whenever I think of the contributors and maintainers of those projects, I feel a little bit bad because they're not getting as much love as they used to.
But they're still great.
But uv is definitely making a splash.
Yeah, that's a good way to think about it.
I get excited about new tools very quickly.
And I don't often think about how the maintainers of the old, the tools that are less popular think of something good.
Yeah, it's the natural way of things, I think.
But it's also tough.
So the speed is important.
One thing I think is interesting, while I think this is especially interesting for data science, and you touched on this already, is I come more from the web API side of Python, I would say.
And over there, it's been pip all day long.
It's been pip the whole time.
But in the data science side, it's really largely been Conda, Anaconda distributions, that kind of thing, Conda environments.
there's been kind of this separation.
And obviously those are all pulling from the same projects.
They're all on GitHub and so on.
But like there has been a little bit of a difference.
And I feel like uv has made a really big splash in data science and kind of bringing those two worlds back together.
What do you think?
Yeah, I agree.
I actually have an article a long time ago.
I think it's probably in Colcult still.
It's called Peep versus Conduct versus Coal Tree.
So I was trying to give a very fair comparison.
I was in favor of poetry.
But, you know, I compared everything.
And something that I had, to be honest, I was not a fan of Condor.
And after the comparison, I was not even more of a fan of Condor because I felt like it's very heavy.
You can use, I think, Mini Condor, so it's quicker.
But at the same time, it installs many dependencies that you didn't ask for.
So it's kind of like a solution where you have a lot of dependencies out of the box, right?
But I find that a lot of times you didn't ask for some dependencies installed.
So you don't really have control over what's being installed, as well as the way that it solves dependencies or not.
I find it's very slow.
So, so poetry was better because, you know, it's cleaner.
You can see like what you put in, you can see like everything in a file.
Like there's a separate file, right?
One for one is what?
PyProject.com and one is a lot.
You want to see all the sub dependencies.
And now uv is to me is like that, but to like, like poetry, but better.
The fact that it can run very fast.
So one drawback of poetry was sometimes it's think very hard about and take a long time to solve, install new dependencies.
And also uv replace X, you know, like it kind of like an all-in-one-place tool, which is, I think, very necessary, especially for, I mean, for everybody who use Python, but for data scientists, you know, they already have so many things going on and tell them to learn, you know, good practices.
You know, let's say they want to upgrade, right, from Python 3.5 to 3.6, 3.7.
To, you know, use other tools, you know, to do it, it seems like a lot.
If you can just use one tool and then you can run it, like upgrading in one command line, then we're not.
Yeah, 100%. I think it's great.
And it has a lot of compatibility with previous workflows.
For example, you can use uv pip install instead of using its project management thing, like with add and sync, right?
So you don't necessarily have to adopt its style.
You can just say instead of pip install, you can say uv pip install.
One of the things that used to bother me, and I honestly just haven't looked for a while, about Ponda was coming from a non-data science side.
Some of the libraries save requests or Flask or something like that.
pyramid. Those were held back quite a bit because they try to make sure there's a compatibility between the versions that they ship through Conda, which is, I think that's good for data science or reproducibility. But when it comes to web frameworks, you've got to be super on top of updates in case there's a security vulnerability. You want to release that thing the day the vulnerability is announced. You want to upgrade your website because as soon as it's announced, people start scanning the internet for any website that could possibly be susceptible to that problem right and so like the web tools were held back a lot so that's i it's one of the reasons i never really
embraced conda yeah but another now that you mentioned it another i i also found it is uh one thing i didn't like about conda is you know like there's let's say data scientists like pandas right if this pandas version is available then a lot of time like sometimes it's not available on conda That's one thing.
But another thing is data scientists, they collaborate with other engineers.
So as someone, they need to hand over to the engineers, like machine learning engineers, data engineers, to use their code.
And I think in my previous company, they didn't use Conda.
So for them to need to install Conda, there's a way for you from Conda to pip.
But then the dependencies look very messy and it's not like a one-to-one translation.
Sometimes you don't get the same environment.
Sure, interesting.
Not the trouble for handing over, right?
And reproducible is a big thing when it comes to data science.
And dependencies play a big part of it.
So if you make it hard to reproduce the dependencies, then there will be some bugs.
there will be some errors and even work silent errors.
core pieces engineers need to deploy multi-agent systems now belong to everyone who builds on agency. You get robust identity and access management, so every agent is authenticated and trusted before it interacts. You get open, standardized tools for agent discovery, clean protocols for agent-to-agent communication, and modular components that let you compose scalable workflows instead of wiring up brittle glue code. Agency is not a walled garden. You'll Cisco, Dell Technologies, Google Cloud, Oracle, Red Hat, and more than 75 supporting companies.
The goal is simple.
Build the next generation of AI infrastructure together in the open so agents can cooperate across tools, vendors, and runtimes.
Agencies dropping code, specs, and services with no strings attached.
Sound awesome?
Well, visit talkpython.fm/agency to contribute.
That's talkpython.fm/A-G-N-T-C-Y.
The link is in your podcast player's show notes and on the episode page.
Thank you as always to Agency for supporting Talk Python To Me.
Next article, let's talk about, I think this is a big one.
Reproducibility, maintainability, that kind of thing.
What you talked about there was kind of a good lead into it, right?
It's like the production engineers need to make sure that what they're running runs the same as what the data scientists have tested and come up with.
And if the situation is different, right, the runtime environment is different, well, maybe it's going to give different answers because of different versions or something.
Yeah, exactly. And dependency is a big thing, but there's also other things that come into it, right, and we can talk about it too.
Yeah, so what are some of the core ideas of reproducibility?
Yeah, so reproducibility, I think, is, and at the heart of reproducibility is you want to, let's say, especially for data scientists, when they create code, right, create machine learning models, it depends on some, there's a lot when it packages dependencies, but also like depends on parameters that you use.
and like, you know, even you use everything the same from experiment to experiment, it can produce slightly different accuracy.
So you want to be able to, let's say one data scientist say, I got a 0.9 accuracy.
Then they give it, head it over to their teammate to deploy.
And then it's degrading the performance.
It's no longer have a 0.9 accuracy.
It probably can be, you know, without 0.8.
And so reproducibility is very important in terms of, you know, you want people, if you produce some result, you want other people to be able to reproduce the same results so that your company can profit out of it.
But another thing is choice, right? Let's say if you data center, you create something that is good, but then you hand it over and it's bad, then it reduces the choice from your co-workers.
The third thing about it is, let's say if data scientists create some project and then later they want to reuse it, right? Like for another project, they cannot reproduce the same results.
then it's kind of like throw it away, creating everything from scratch.
So it also time consuming.
And another big theme after producing, I think go hand in hand is maintainability.
But yeah, you can go ahead.
Yeah, no, I totally agree.
The maintainability part is super important as well.
And so what are some of the pieces that go into that?
I mean, the first thing that comes to mind for me is pinning your dependencies, either through using something like uv init, uv add, uv sync, or just a requirements.txt file or pinning your requirements, you know, through some other means like with poetry, but somehow clearly documenting what's used.
I think it can be easy for data scientists to just import some things in a notebook and then do a magic, well, uv pip install that right here and let's just keep going.
But then like, why won't it run later, you know?
Yeah, are you talking about maintainability or reproducibility?
Well, I was thinking maintainability, but both, yeah.
So maintainability, another thing is, another aspect that comes into maintainability is readability, right?
And I think this is a big thing for data scientists.
A lot of data scientists don't write readable code and modular code.
what you will see is like a big chunk of code with like nested if else or using global variables inside a function or not using function at all and there's a lot of duplicate in the code and I mean that is great for quick experimentation like you want to get something out of it but at the same time it's create a lot of technical debt in terms of this multiple thing that leads to not readable, right? So, and I can go deeper, I just want to list it out, readability and then reproducibility. And readability, you want your code to be readable because data scientists collaborate with other engineers. And if your code, and also another problem I saw is data scientists, they cannot read their old code in like a couple of months.
They forgot. They won't be right. They're really like, what did I write? And they spend quite bit of time to understand what they write and if they cannot understand or they don't trust it right
if you don't understand in a full level you cannot trust it and you cannot use the next project
a lot of times they write things from scratch again so readability also if your code is not written well readability and reproducibility you cannot it's harder to reproduce the same result because let's say global variables, you use global variables and it affects your code, then it's hard.
You might introduce some external factors that make the code different the next time you run.
So managing really is very important
and that comes with, sorry, write readable code, version control, dependencies management, configuration management,
meaning you don't want to hard code the values into your code.
Yeah, this is a really great article here because it shows you so many tools and techniques, I think.
Yeah, thank you.
And I also, so writing a maintainable data science project has been my passion for a long period of time.
And it actually has become a book like this.
This is the article form, but I also recently wrote a book about this, finished a book about this.
It's called Production Ready Data Science.
Yeah, congratulations.
That's amazing.
When did you finish it?
When did you publish it?
Two months ago, I think.
Okay, so really recently, yeah.
Very recently.
It took me quite a while.
I have other materials because I've been writing about this.
I have so many materials who put it together and also make it less in an article style, explaining more of the why before the how is also what I focus a lot on this book.
Yeah, that's a super important part.
Now, I am a huge fan of thinking a lot about readability and spending a lot of time on readability.
And I agree with you.
I think we're on the same page for sure on that one because if your code is not readable, that doesn't mean it can't be read.
It just means it's harder to read, right?
If your code is not readable, it's harder to maintain it.
It's harder to see the bugs.
It's harder to read.
All the things that you've pointed out.
And I think it's a little bit ironic that the notebook style of development that is meant to communicate, like it's supposed to be more communication compared to regular programming, right?
It's got the markdown cells.
It's got the pictures.
It's got little tables for like df.head, that kind of stuff, right?
It's natural way of programming it leads to less maintainable, reusable code, right?
Because it does not encourage functions.
It's really hard to do reuse if you don't think, oh, maybe I need to write a function in this cell, collapse the cell, and then use the function later.
That happens, but not very much.
I was doing some research for, or just looking around, really.
Research is a little bit high, putting it in a high position compared to what it was.
I was looking around for some examples, and I found this really cool JPL collection of notebooks for studying, I think, galaxies.
like studying the brightness of galaxies and trying to understand things about them.
And they had a bunch of cool notebooks in there.
And they were like 1,500 lines of code and stuff in there.
One function, one.
Wow.
I'm like, oh, that is probably, I mean, maybe this is necessary, but it's probably not necessary.
And this is JPL, right?
This is like a polished published thing, not just a random notebook I ran across, right?
the Jet Propulsion Laboratory in Pasadena, which is, I consider them to be pretty amazing.
So maybe speak through a little bit about that,
like this maintainability thing in juxtaposition with notebook style.
Yeah, definitely.
That's the thing.
Before, I think five years ago, I wrote an article that got very popular, but also a lot of controversy.
It's called, I think, something about seven reasons why I switched from notebook to Python script or something.
But so anyway, so the thing about Notebook is a lot of people argue, yeah, you can write functions.
Like it's just Python, right?
You can write functions.
You can write whatever you want, just like a Python script.
But the interactive style of it kind of discourages you from doing it.
Like why should I write a function when I can just like see the result and then I build upon it, right?
Because in Notable, what is so great about it is you can see the results and then you can build up upon it in the next cell, next cell, next cell.
So people are less likely to build a function, which like if you create a function, then like it's hide inside a function.
It's not execute the code.
So that's one thing.
Another thing problematic about Notable is it's encouraged hard coding, you know, like a lot of time.
Because if you want to see the result, you want to put your value in there to see the result.
But another thing is, a very big problem is cell execution, right?
If you execute cell, the fact that it gives you the ability to execute in different orders is nice, but also a disadvantage in a way that if you run it in the wrong order, then it will, like, you can get some result right now that is different from result that you want to run.
Right.
If you forget to run a particular cell, you go back up, run that to refresh it, and then you skip back down.
Something in the middle was important and you don't rerun it.
That's probably not good.
Yeah, exactly.
And that's, I remember when I worked in notebook before, it just gave me a headache because I would run something.
I said, oh, did I rerun this?
Like, did I run that score or did I not?
Just to make sure I'll rerun it.
So it's something.
And then later, when I come back to notebook, I was like, I'm not going to reuse this notebook again because I don't know what's going on here.
Yeah.
I don't want people to think that I'm completely anti-notebook.
I'm not.
But I do think that there are some techniques and some tips that you can use.
So when I was riffing on functions, one thing I think you could do, and you touched on it as well, is you could take the parts of your code that you want to reuse and put that in a Python script next to your notebook and import it, right?
And then you can use it.
A lot of times, I think there's a bunch of cells in notebooks that don't really have to do with the presentation or the important part they're just there like well i need to load this thing or i need to like clean up that or or something and it has to go before what you actually want to show people you could put that in a script yeah and you could just show import it and then show the important part right it's more readable more reusable it's more modular like in all ways almost it's better yes i agree i the thing about yes i'm like notebook is great it's very
good for presentation but i think the problem is a lot of time people use it more than what it's supposed to desire for which is i mean it's prototype right it's to uh showcase uh something it to to showcase it with um either non-technical or technical people it's not used for like everything and and i think that's a problem like a lot of the scientists use it for everything including uh ready production ready code and again that's another argument right like can you production ready code in notebook and Netflix did that.
Netflix create production ready code in notebooks and that's great.
Paper mill and all that stuff.
Yeah.
That technology allows you to do it.
I feel like it's still, but then Temtem is, it's a tool that if you use the right, then it will serve you.
Yeah.
It's, it's interesting.
Speaking of tools, I know you've written about, talked a little bit about Marimo.
What do you think about that?
I think this is a really interesting one.
I just did a sort of, I did a course called Just Enough Python and it's software engineering for data scientists.
Nice.
And I was trying, thanks.
Yeah.
And it's like, okay, a lot of themes that you talk about as well, like you should probably learn Git, you know, and so on.
But one of the things I really struggled with was I really wanted to use Marimo as the foundation, but, you know, 90% or more data scientists use Jupyter.
So I ended up using Jupyter, but I think Marimo actually might be a little bit better in terms of software engineering and a little bit better in terms of this order of operations you talked about, like, because Marimo tracks like, hey, this cell depends upon that cell. So if you rerun this one, we got to rerun that one first. It'll catch those kind of things. But you want to maybe talk about this real quick? Because I know you wrote about it a little
bit. Yeah, I really like Marimo. I think it's great. It has been, so I was actually in the middle of writing the book, right? And I know that people, data scientists love Notebook and I don't want to be like, hey, let's just write Python script. But at the same time, I really think that Notebook is really hard to write production radical. And that's, you know, my book is about production radical. So how do you find the middle ground between, you know, an interactive version of Notebook and production radical? So Marimor came out and I dig deep into it. It solved a lot problems and first is a self-execution order right so the problem in notebook is let's say you cell one cell two cell three you change something in cell one for example you all run it but then you change something in cell one if you forgot to rerun cell three then um you know the result is not going to reflect what you have changed in cell one but with marimold it can detect the dependencies. And if you change cell 1 and cell 3 depend on cell 1, depend on the variable in cell 1, then it will execute it automatically, which is great. Another big thing is, you know, notebook, not disadvantage, notebook is JavaScript, right? So it's very big, unreadable, hard to, if you want to use it or hand it over, reuse it. It's really hard.
Right. It's so common to get a Git conflict when you try to pull a new version just because the output has changed.
And that shouldn't even be taken into account, right?
And yeah, that shouldn't be taken into account.
And also the output can be big.
But with Marimode, not only just a Python script under the hood.
So you have the...
And what great thing about Python script is you can reuse it.
You can import it in another Python script.
but also for CI/CD, right?
And you can write unit tests.
You know, like with unit tests are important, but with in Notebook, you can write unit tests.
There's a hacker out, but it's a hack.
And sometimes people need to put their tests inside Notebook, which is not modular, right?
It's not, it's make it very messy with code and then tests inside the same place.
But if you write notebook that is Python script under the hood, then you can write unit tests and you can run it with pytest.
Yeah, very cool.
I think this is a neat one.
I generally wanted to use it, but I'm like, but at the same time, I probably got to speak the same language of the people doing that.
Exactly.
Yeah, yeah.
Another thing I want to talk about here, actually this maintainability article has just got so much good stuff in it.
Something I think that might be new to folks is Hydra, right?
Let's talk about this idea of managing configuration files with Hydra.
Yeah, I love Hydra.
So Hydra is developed by Facebook Research, and I think I use it.
It has been my two goals.
So I have some core tools.
I go back for every data science project, and Hydra is one of them.
I guess if you think about Hydra is a configuration management tool, you can write your configuration inside a YAML file, and then you can call things.
You can access the variables inside the YAML file inside a Python script.
That is nothing new.
People know about there's a YAML muting library in Python that allows you to work with YAML.
But something I like about HIDL a lot is reduce the boilerplate code.
So you can just add an app like a decorator to your Python function.
And then it will be able to access everything underneath inside the Python function.
And instead of using a bracket notation, like for example, if to access a nested value, you might need to use mutable nested function, but instead you can use dot notation, which is very clean.
Other things are,
oh, you can, as your project getting bigger, right?
I mean, for a small project, maybe a YAML is enough, but as your project getting bigger, let's say you have, you want to be able to use, especially in like data science experimentation, you want to use different values.
You want to experiment with different way of processing.
You want to experiment with different parameters for your models.
And that can get messy.
Your YAML file becomes very big.
So a good way to handle this is you want to break it into smaller configuration.
But if you want to do that without Hydra, then you need to write Python functions to access it, to composite it, to put it together, put the pieces of puzzle together.
With Hydra, you can basically, everything is handled for you.
So you can break it apart and then you can refer to different part of the pieces.
You can, like in one YAML file, you can refer to the other part of the YAML file.
It's kind of like an import, right?
Import in Python.
And you can override it.
Another thing I realized, you can override the parameter from the command line.
Yeah, that's a cool feature.
Yeah, so you don't need to go back into the, because a lot of time you want to experiment.
different parameters or inside the production environment and the development environment, you might use different parameters.
And if you can override from the command line, which is used a lot in different platforms, then that will be amazing.
Yeah, it's super neat.
Basically, you provide a bunch of default values instead of hard coding them.
And then if you need to override them, you can do that through the command line or you could just do it in code or whatever, right?
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
Yeah, excellent.
And you bring it all together here in your article, uv run process, so you got your Hydra, you got your uv run coming together, all that stuff.
So you actually have a whole article.
I originally started talking about it because it was in the maintainability section, but you have a whole article called Hydra for Python Configuration, right?
Yeah, the other article is more like a high level, but then I have smaller articles that talk about each tool.
Super.
Okay, well, we're not making very good progress through this, but that's okay.
Because these are really interesting topics.
Another one that you talk a lot about is doing proper logging.
And you recommend Log Guru, which I love Log Guru.
I think it's really great.
I used Log Book for a long time from Armin Roeneker.
But then I've been slowly moving towards Log Guru.
Nice.
Yeah, I really like.
So another thing about, you know, like a lot of data scientists, they use print, which nothing wrong with print.
Like, in fact, you shouldn't use, I think it's overkill.
You use print in a notebook, right?
But when it comes to, like, if you want to run production ready code, if you have a bunch of prints, because a lot of times you had debugging prints, right?
And if, yeah, you can go back and, like, delete them and everything.
But wouldn't it be great?
But then, like, if you go back to development environment, then you need to, like, put it back.
Or if you don't do it at all, if you keep all the prints inside your code, You go into development, now you have a bunch of noise when you see the output.
So with logging, just a simple way of you thinking about, I think a big advantage of logging is you can do logging and you can use different modes like debug, info, warning, error.
So you can set the level based on, you can show, let's say if you go into your in development environment, you want to show the debug level.
If you go into the production environment, then you might want to do like the info level only.
But one drawback of logging is, I think it's tech, quite a bit of boilerplate code.
That's the first thing.
So it really, even if you can pop in paste, even it's like one barrier, you know, like one barrier to use logging.
Why should I do all of this code when I can just use print?
Right, it's got like, you got to register handlers and all sorts of funky stuff, yeah.
But what if you can have the advantage of print, like so easy to use, and the benefit of logging?
Then that's why I'm such a big fan of Loggeroo, which have the best of both worlds.
And other things that it allows this beautiful app in the box.
So the logging output, it looks colorful.
It's very easy to see.
With a standard logging, you need to do a lot of, you know, what do you want to show?
You want to show this, you want to show the lines of code, you want to show the function, whereas the output is coming from all those configurations.
With Loggeroo, you can just say from Loggeroo import Logger and then Logger.info something, something.
And the output is very beautiful.
Yeah, I really like it.
You can basically just, if you wanted to kind of keep your print style, you can just import it and use it and it's prints, right?
Yeah.
The other thing, like you pointed out, this is a super big, for people who are primarily data scientists who haven't worked with logging a lot or new programming, instead of just saying logger print, you say logger debug or logger info or logger error.
And then you can say, production, just show me the errors.
Or, hey, something's going wrong.
Actually, show me all the warnings and the info.
And you can dial it up and down without changing the code.
So you can leave your effective print statements there and just turn them off with a configuration.
Maybe with Hydra, who knows?
Yeah.
Yeah, really nice.
and the color and the color is very nice as well it's very colorful yeah it's and the color it
persists through files by the way right so if you have log guru logging to a file and then you tail
the file in your terminal you see the color still which is awesome oh wow i didn't know that that's a
yeah yeah because some of my stuff is all logging um with log guru and i tell and the color comes through and it's wow so much easier um like for example on the website one of the things that i'm logging to a separate file is what are the requests what is the response time what is the status code is it a 500 is it 200 is it a three you know whatever right all that and so i'll actually have it change the color based on what happens so if the message is a 500 it's a different color than if it's a 200 or if the response time is over 500 milliseconds it changes color to like a warning sign versus if it's under like and it all that stuff comes true and it's like so nice with log
Nice. Yeah. Especially when you have a lot of logs and that is very useful.
Yeah, absolutely. Okay. Git. Let's talk about source control.
Yeah. Version control is, I think it's, it's huge. It's very useful. and it's very important for data scientists, but I don't see it's being used enough.
I was in, yeah, and the last thing I actually, I was a machine learning engineer in Accenture and working with clients.
So I was building kind of like a data science environment, data science tool that integrated with AWS SageMaker.
And it's funny how many data scientists are not using Git and like their multiple data science team.
And they want to communicate with each other.
You know, they want to share their work.
But then every time they want to share their work, it's so hard for them because they don't have a source version control, which surprised me.
You know, it's a big client.
I mean, it's a big one.
Why don't they use it?
And if they do, it's not very good practices.
So that's why I want to educate the scientists more about it.
And to me, yeah, this is so important for several reasons.
First, let's say if you do something, right, you mess up some code.
Let me give an example of data scientists.
They produce, they write a model.
They write code that produces a model that works great.
Then, like, later, they want to switch parameters, maybe experiment with different types of processing, see if the model performance can increase and they mess it up.
The model decreases in performance and they have edited two or three files.
Now they need to, okay, what did I edit?
Now I need to revert it.
And if you don't already save the last version that was working,
you cannot just revert to it, right?
But with Git, you can, there's multiple things.
If you're just a solo data scientist, then you can revert it to the last working version.
But if you work with other data scientists, then you can share, you can also collaborate with them.
Different data scientists can work on different versions or different features.
And when they're ready for it to be published, then they can merge it together, which is so much better when you do it with Git than manually going life to life.
I think I agree with you. I think data scientists don't use source control or version control enough. And I think that even when people work alone on their own project, they should use Git or something else. And honestly, they should just use Git these days because it's the lingua franca of everything that people are doing.
But it lets you do exactly what you're talking about.
And it's not just, oh, no, I have to go back.
But I think a really important part of people,
speaking to the people who don't really use it that much,
or they only use it in their professional settings in the team, maybe, I think it lets you be fearless in exploring new ideas, right?
Like, all right, I'm going to commit this version.
And then let me just terrorize my code and try something crazy.
And oh, my gosh, it worked.
Great, we'll keep it.
If it doesn't work, nothing lost.
you can 100% go back.
And if people don't, if they're not, I mean, that's a good reason even by yourself, right?
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
And it's, I feel like it's so easy.
You can do git add, git commit.
I mean, there's a lot of things you can do with git, but I think to just learn some basic, git add, git commit, git push.
That's it.
Yeah.
Yeah, there's not, you don't have to learn, there's maybe five or six commands you got to learn.
Mostly your tools that you're working with.
You mentioned VS Code.
It's got awesome git.
Oh, yeah.
Control integration and PyCharm and others.
Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
I think that's really, really nice.
Let me give you two more ideas and see how these land with you, okay?
For why I think Git is now more important than ever.
Yeah.
Number one, if you're doing any agentic coding, here's another reason to use like a proper editor instead of a notebook as well, potentially.
But you can go and say, hey, AI agent, I would like you to change this and add this feature and do this thing.
And it'll just go and go for, you know, 10, 15 minutes.
If what I find a lot of times with these agentic coding things is they make great progress.
You're like, wow, this is amazing.
It makes more great progress.
Like, how is this even possible?
I live in the future.
And then the next step is, oh, no, it broke it all.
You know what I mean?
So you're like, yeah, yeah.
You have the same experience.
Yes.
And I love that you go into this topic because that's kind of I think of the mathematics I have been mentioned, it's more important than ever now that you have AI, you're working with AI.
Because two different things, right?
A lot of time, you wanted to do something and then it broke.
So you want to go back to the previous version.
That's one thing.
Another thing is if you commit very frequently, then you can see what it changed.
And you can take it before you commit it or you push.
Because I think it's so frequently that I do something that is not optimal.
For example, Mutiful Nested.
Like with AI, a lot of times it overcomplicates the solution.
It makes it so many tries, exec, accept, and if, else, or like it uses.
It's hard code.
It's just bad practices.
But if you control, you use version control, you can see like the difference.
like the last call and the new call and you can catch it before you commit and yeah yeah it's more
important than ever i 100 yeah you're 100 right you're right on it i find that when i'm doing the
agentic coding side of things i actually have the source control tab open in my editor not the files tab but the source control and as it's going i'll see what files are changed and i'll start like looking at the diffs even while it's still working i'm like oh it's on a good path oh no this it shouldn't be doing this and either you ask it to fix it or you just go no i'm reverting it yeah i added a feature to the website not a super big one but kind of touched a lot of files i think there was 15 commits to achieve that that change because every time a major i'm like okay the ai has gotten something right i'm like save that to get yes take because because it's it's like exactly like you
described it's awesome yeah i i experienced the same like i would have so many commits for like want future change because also something that I tell to do is uh you know just let's say if I want to implement like a something I really like to do is go very thoroughly with like planning very very thoroughly in advance before even code to ensure like everything is uh what I expected and then I let it run right um and what I did depends on what I run I do but recently I tried develop like a workflow to go from you know my code into newsletter so I wanted to implement something uh and I want to be I want to be able to walk away and go back and and be able to go back to each so I break into phases like let's say I break into five phases right the um the easiest and the more complicated phase, like the nicer have feature.
Now I want to go back into each phase and see if it breaks.
I want to know when it breaks.
So for every phase, ask it to commit.
So that, you know, if I want to,
if it breaks somewhere,
I can go back to the previous version, which also another thing that you can ask it to commit.
Yeah, yeah.
That's interesting.
I haven't thought about asking it to commit.
That's cool.
I'll give you one final reason
to use Git in the agentic world.
And then I think we're out of time.
I'm going to have to call it.
But this has been a great conversation.
One other thing you talked about, like, oh, it's made good progress and then something didn't work.
And you can actually tell it.
You gave your example.
Let me make this more concrete.
You gave your example of, oh, I made some changes as, forget the AI, right?
I made some changes.
It turns out that the performance fell apart.
I edited three files.
I couldn't quite remember what was wrong.
You could go to an agentic AI and say,
please look at my local Git history from this commit forward and try to understand why the performance fell apart.
And I bet you it will have some really good ideas, if not know exactly why.
And it will do what we described for us in reverse.
It'll just look at the Git history and go, this changed, this changed.
Oh, if this changed, I bet it had this effect.
And then, right.
So you can leverage it in reverse and feed it to the AI to get understanding too.
Yeah, yeah.
That's such a great use case that you just talked about a lot of time.
You're like, okay, use GitDiv.
look at the difference and tell me what's wrong.
That's another thing that I use very often.
Also, another thing on top of it is, let's say it doesn't code the way you, like everybody has the old preferred style to do things, right?
So sometimes you can edit it and you tell it, okay, look at your implementation and my implementation and just kind of taking notes of the difference so that the next time it will be able to create
similar, more similar to the style you're looking for. Yeah. Yeah. That's a great idea. I feel like we honestly could talk about this for hours, but we're out of time. We're out of time, Quinn. So thank you for being here. I think let's leave it with this. Let's leave it with two things.
First of all, maybe final call to action. People are interested in CodeCut AI, all of the stuff you've created. How do they get started with all of your resources? Yes. So just go to my website,
Codecut, so C-O-D-E-C-U-T dot A-I.
And then you will see how to sign up for newsletter.
There's also a book tab that if you want to, if you're interested in production, ready data science, you can buy it there.
It's currently on sales.
It's Labor Day week.
So 20% off.
And yeah, that's it.
And if you want to read my blog, go to blog.
If you want to see a sample of my code snippet, go to short post.
Everything is very easy to navigate.
Just go to Word.ai.
Fantastic.
All right.
Well, thank you so much for being here and sharing all your experience and your work.
Really, congratulations on CodeCut.
It's a cool project.
Thank you so much.
You bet.
See you later.
We'll see you.
Bye.
This has been another episode of Talk Python To Me.
Thank you to our sponsors.
Be sure to check out what they're offering.
It really helps support the show.
Take some stress out of your life.
Get notified immediately about errors and performance issues in your web or mobile applications with Sentry.
Just visit talkpython.fm/sentry and get started for free.
And be sure to use the promo code talkpython, all one word.
Agency.
Discover agentic AI with agency.
Their layer lets agents find, connect, and work together, any stack, anywhere.
Start building the internet of agents at talkpython.fm/agency, spelled A-G-N-T-C-Y.
Want to level up your Python? We have one of the largest catalogs of Python video courses over at Talk Python. Our content ranges from true beginners to deeply advanced topics like memory and async.
And best of all, there's not a subscription in sight. Check it out for yourself at training.talkpython.fm.
Be sure to subscribe to the show, open your favorite podcast app, and search for Python.
We should be right at the top. You can also find the iTunes feed at /itunes, the Google Play feed at /play, and the direct RSS feed at /rss on talkpython.fm.
We're live streaming most of our recordings these days. If you want to be part of the show and have your comments featured on the air, be sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel at talkpython.fm/youtube. This is your host, Michael Kennedy. Thanks so much for listening. I really appreciate it. Now get out there and write some Python code.
We'll be right back.